if we're gonna be miserable at least
we're being miserable together I think
that's actually the best summary of Game
of Thrones yeah we're here to play [ __ ]
merry red wedding with the Game of
Thrones characters aka
[ __ ] Khal Drogo kill Volans and marry
Robb Stark I have a feeling we're here
to make a lot of really tough decisions
tough decisions oh they'll be pretty
easy for me I think I want to both marry
and be Daenerys Targaryen I can safely
say Tywin he's a man with a plan and I
got to have a man with a plan and a man
with a lot of money Jon Snow is my
favorite game of Thrones character he's
still on the market we don't really need
Jon Snow I feel like he's just there
stirring up a bunch of crap he's a
little older okay yeah I think he's
overrated
I'm so ready all men must die winters
here we're the dead dad's cuz everyone's
dad is dead well this is easy kill
Robert Baratheon kill him like a wild
boar I would love to marry or have
relations with Khal Drogo I think marry
Ned Stark I mean we all know what
happens to him I mean like he's a good
man ya know I would probably go a little
crazy if I was married to Robert
Baratheon young powerful women
oh we know this is hard I love them all
can I marry them all
I'd kill Cersei because she's a [ __ ] I
don't want to [ __ ] her eat you there but
I also feel like she would know some
crazy [ __ ] and but I'm still gonna kill
her before I red wedding her I'd want to
have a glass of wine with her
then I would [ __ ] Marjorie she's hot
she's young and you could f her brother
afterwards oh yes
okay nerd alert here there should be an
e and my wife's name Denarius she knows
what she doing all sexy I'm gonna marry
Denarius because I don't want to be one
of generic sucide pieces oh my god this
is the easiest one
what is pretty one of the easiest ones
I'm not gonna lie I didn't really know
who this was wait and cheering well I
already know who I'm gonna kill now a
look at the other pimple wow that was
ridiculous
[ __ ] Theon Greyjoy obviously a freak
Ramsay Bolton I'll be his last yeah I
mean go out with a bang I'm gonna marry
Rob even though a little idealistic and
probably wouldn't keep us alive very
well but thank you
Marta Ned Stark than I am Rob but you
know I'll take him Oh No oh no not the
phrase oh my god Joffrey sorry just kill
him can we put them all up very very
good oh this one's horrible
what a horrible what is it I would kill
Walder Frey again and again and again
and again
Joffrey even [ __ ] I wouldn't call what
any of these men do with women [ __ ]
perfect I definitely wouldn't kill Frey
because I know that he's gonna die
anyway I normally can't even get hit a
husband I don't do by the size of his
family it looks like he can this game
has just taught me that most of the
people in Game of Thrones are terrible
people that you would never want to do
any of those things I'm betting
association yeah the show is complicated
the decisions we made today are
complicated but that's how I feel about
the show it's conflicting and I like
that I just wish I could have killed
Joffrey and Ramsay no one would ever be
like you know where I want to live
Westeros
No
[Music]